i get asked all the time hey do i need  to like grow my social media if i'm  selling social media services do i need  to be super jacked if i'm selling weight  loss or fitness in terms of like do i  need to have walk the walk etc the  answer is you should know how to get  there i ended up selling my gyms before  i ended up helping a lot of gym owners  grow their businesses the fact that i  didn't have the gyms at the time in no  way questioned my authority and my  ability to help them do it because what  you need to articulate is not have i  done it but have i taken people just  like you where you want to go and how  many times have i done that and if you  can articulate depth of the prospect  then it doesn't matter whether you have  a six-pack or you're just in medium  shape because at the end of the day if  you've taken 100 people who look just  like them to where they want to go  you're credit worthy and more  creditworthy than just some guy with a  six-pack